hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
kochwelt heute gibt es mal wieder was
türkisches und zwar kennen vielleicht
viele von euch mahnte das sind so diese
türkischen maultaschen sag jetzt mal und
ich mach jetzt heute aber nicht die
original kleine mahnte sommer es gibt so
ziert ermahnte und zwar ist es dass man
praktisch sondern nudelteig macht und
den wänden ausrollt und david gefüllt
mit hackfleisch kann auch eine andere
füllung nehmen und es wird an so einer
strecke gerollt und im ofen gebacken
schmeckt aber so ähnlich wie die
türkischen also wie die kleinen
maultaschen aber ich natürlich in der
herstellung einfacher und viel schneller
das mache ich nämlich immer ganz gern
wenn ich mal lust auf man vorab
unterwandert zu viel zeit oder keine
lust habe die kleine dinge alle zusammen
so vorstellen und ich sag ich jetzt
einfach mal wie ich die hersteller für
den teig brauch ich 500 gramm mehl 1
einen halben teelöffel salz und bisschen
wasser da nehme ich so ungefähr 200 bis
250 gramm kommt darauf an wie groß ist
das ist auch ganz schnell ich mache es
jetzt in der küchenmaschine könnte
natürlich auch per hand verkneten
aber das ist natürlich bisschen
anstrengender weil der nudelteig so ein
bisschen festerer teig ist habe ich das
mehl darin gibt einfach mit dazu dann
auch direkt das salz und vom wasser gebe
ich jetzt erstmal so drei viertel mehr
dazu also etwa 200 milliliter und
verknetet sind und gibt dann bei bedarf
noch mal wasser mit rein so dass ein
schöner feste aber ein geschmeidiger
teig entsteht
so sieht jetzt der fertige teig aus also
das ist ein sehr schöner fester aber
sehr geschmeidigen teig und ich habe den
jetzt ungefähr acht minuten kneten
lassen
also wenn ihr denn mit der hand genähten
dauert es genau so lange ich lasse jetzt
noch ausruhen könnte entweder in
frischhaltefolie machen oder damit man
jetzt in folie verschwinden einfach in
eine schüssel deckel drauf und dann
lasse ich ihn hier an der seite stehen
in der zeit kann ich jetzt schon meine
füllung vorbereiten
dafür brauche ich hier eine zwiebel dann
habe ich hier 500 gramm rinder
hackfleisch ich hab pfeffer salz und
chili und es war mir da eine
vegetarische füllung zum beispiel machen
wollt können daher zum beispiel
kartoffeln nehmen oder irgendwas anderes
halten die zwiebel und schnaitsee so ein
bisschen klein und bis jetzt klein mixen
ihr könnt aber auch zum beispiel klein
reiben
das mache ich jetzt kurz in der
küchenmaschine
jetzt die zwiebeln mit zum hackfleisch
mit dazu und würzt das ganze mit salz
pfeffer ein bisschen chili
und dann vermisse ich das einfach nicht
schön miteinander
ich habe mir zehn eine auflaufform
gerichtet gleich für meine nudel
schnecken und die habe ich jetzt mit
etwas olivenöl also mosel ausstreichen
mache ich einfach mit einem silikon
pinsel schnell einfach damit sei jetzt
gleich die nudel schnecken lenz drin
kleben bleiben
beim packen das reicht oft schon das
kann ich zur seite stellen und jetzt
muss ich den teig ausrollen also
normalerweise ist es so dass man es dem
teig viertel
das machen wir denn auch das ist jetzt
auch nicht so nudelteig im klassischen
sinne irgendwie eigentlich auch schon
aber bisher nicht weil man kann der
nudel tiger verschiedene arten machen
entweder macht man sie nur mit ein
oder man macht halt nur mit wasser kann
man auch ein veganes tag mache deshalb
irgendwo wilde mischung und ich teile
jetzt den durch 4
und normalerweise würde ich jetzt meinen
großen ausbau statt nehmen also blind
türkischen das opfer war und wird dann
vier große lüfters ausrollen
aber weil das natürlich sehr anstrengend
ich mache ich das jetzt mit der
nudelmaschine denn mit der kann man
genauso dünn arbeiten
und wahrscheinlich hat kameraleute von
euch eine küchenmaschine alten aus
hollstadt und das ganze geht viel
schneller und deswegen macht man es dazu
jetzt nehme ich mir eins der vier teile
und bemalt ist ganz ganz leicht und
drückt ist ein bisschen flach bis in die
breite
da hätte es noch ein bisschen mehr mehr
vertragen also wenn man bisserl mail zum
ausrollen braucht dann heißt eigentlich
das dauert ein bisschen zu feucht ist
also ich hätten auch gleich zu machen
können und hätte dann auch kein mehl zum
ausräumen gebraucht und jetzt staatlich
jetzt hier einfach da stufe eins also
bei der dik schulstufe gebt den teig
oben rein und die maschine erledigt die
ganze arbeiten ist dann wird auch noch
umklappen das hatte das schneidige wird
und ich bin einfach noch mal durch
jetzt werde ich immer dünner und wechsel
einfach da oben von 1 ab 2
die geschwindigkeit zu erhöhen
das einfach immer dünner werden und bei
mir geht es super 9 und ich werde bis
super 8 aber ausbauen
jetzt starte ich mal mit dem ersten
stück und beispiel ziemlich lang
deswegen halte ich das jetzt natürlich
mag hier ungefähr die mitte und nehme
dann einfach ich nehme diese marzipan
messer weil ich jetzt nicht hier
schneiden will
ansonsten mache ich das hier immer auf
meiner holzoberfläche und nimmt eine
normales messer aber marzipan messer
geht auch brot insgesamt entstehen
später so 16 uhr durch schnecken und
wenn ihr jetzt sagt ich hab keine
nudelmaschine aber auch nicht den dünnen
aus hollstadt zum ganz dünn ausrollen
können natürlich auch ein ganz normaler
ausrutscht abnehmen es macht auch nichts
wenn der teig so ein bisschen dicker
wird
und jetzt teile ich mir hier zuerst noch
den teig einmal mittig durch also aus
einem teig stück entstehen praktisch
vier schnecken und jetzt funktioniere
ich mir hier auch die füllung so ein
bisschen also durch 4
dann habt also ungefähr an richtwert und
könnt sagen okay ein viertel davon nehme
ich jetzt also ein sechzehntel davon und
das verteile ich jetzt hier am rand ganz
dünn
und dann rolle ich das hier auf zu einer
langen rolle und verschließt praktisch
diesen hackfleisch das hackfleisch
streng kann übrigens auch mit euren
kindern machen also dessen hat mir alte
samira dabei geholfen da beim
verschließen und beim schnecken rollen
weil es wirklich ganz einfach geht
und dann rolle ich das ganze zu einer
schnecke auf und das ende verstecke ich
jetzt hier unter der schnecke und kann
das ganze jetzt hier drüben in meine
form reinsetzen
und so mache ich es einfach mit dem
restlichen teig bis der komplette zeit
und die füllung aufgebraucht sind und
dann zeige ich euch gleich es weitergeht
ich habe zwölf stück bereits fertig
gemacht und beim letzten stück möchte
ich euch zeigen wie ich das ganze ohne
nudelmaschine mache nämlich mit einem
aus hall starb damit ihr einfach
westphal tier keine nudelmaschine habe
wie ihr das dann eben ansonsten macht
einfach sinn teilnehmen und rund
ausrollen da hole ich sitz hat und aus
war's halt einfacher geht
und mit so einem ausrutscher abgetan ist
schwieriger als es mit dem typischen
drängen opfer also mit diesem langen
dünnen starb mit mehr kraft mitbringen
mit dem ausbau starb ich sehr
anstrengend deswegen zeige ich euch
jetzt da kann ich nämlich den arbeiten
weil ich den tag darauf wolf und dann
durch so eine leichte bewegung hat nach
außen hinweg rolle
ich habe hier immer mittel wenig platz
deswegen arbeite ich immer gern auf der
holzplatte aber wenn ich mich zu stellen
zieht man da brauche ich keine kraft und
also schon ein bisserl kraft aber es
geht halt viel einfacher
also wenn also die größeren habt und das
so ziemlich dünn ist reicht es auch dann
bis es mehr abklopfen
das ein bisschen anders schneiden geht's
wirklich das nämlich so und dann kommt
werden auch hackfleisch gelungen aber
nur hier oben am rand
und dann wird es hier auch aufgerollt
ihr seht dann auch das ist eine kürzere
schlange sag ich jetzt mal und auch eine
kleinere und dickere schnecke
und dies setzt sich jetzt in der
separate vormwald die andere vor mir
schon zu voll ist und wenn ich jetzt
alleine vermittler man mit samira dann
würde ich jetzt nur diese strecken hier
vorbereiten und wir essen pro person so
etwa also ich schaff 3-schlappe murat
schafft sogar 5 und verschafft so 1 bis
2 wenn er hat nur das essen wenn es noch
eine vorspeise gibt und salat dazu dann
schafft man jeweils so ein weniger und
wenn wir jetzt ganz allein werden würde
die vier jetzt einfach einfrieren also
in so einer super schüssel oder jetzt
immer mehr daheim
deswegen mag ich jetzt alle aus aber das
schaut auch super geeignet leben
eintreten kann
und dann kam es bei bedarf einfach auf
button die kommen jetzt in den
vorgeheizten backofen bei 200 10 grad
ober und unterhitze für ungefähr 20
minuten und nach 20 minuten werde ich
sehe mit etwas gemüsebrühe übergießen
weil jetzt werden sie erst mal knusprig
und bekommt sowieso recht aroma und dann
wenn die gemüse brüder zukommt wenn sie
schön weich und man kann halt di noto
schneck auch essen
aber das zeigt
also die nudeln schmecken man jetzt 25
minuten im ofen und sind schön goldbraun
und ich habs jetzt schon mit einem liter
gemüsebrühe übergossen
die kamera hat noch nicht mit
aufgenommen aber ich zeige euch das
jetzt einfach
also ich hab's halt so begossen dass sie
komplett bedeckt sind und es müsste ganz
vorsichtig machen ansonsten kann es
nämlich spritzen wobei man danach den
backofen sauber machen muss weil nämlich
das ganze sowieso jetzt noch mal
aufgekocht und so bleiben die jetzt mit
der gemüsebrühe noch mal 20 minuten im
ofen bis sie die gemüsebrühe aufgezogen
haben in der zwischenzeit werde ich
meinen joghurt vorbereiten und dann
können wir gleich servieren
seine nudeln schmecken sind gebacken ich
hab den backofen ausgemacht und die sind
jetzt noch einen backofen damit sie warm
bleiben und ich mache jetzt den joghurt
und noch die soße für obendrauf
und zwar habe ich dafür einen
zehnprozentigen besten stichfesten
joghurt dann brauche ich bisher
knoblauch ich nehme es nur eine halbe c
oder katze ein bisschen nur sind auch
pfeffer und salz und dann brauche ich
für die soße noch etwas paprikapulver
scharfes und ein bisserl butter erstmal
den joghurt agentin zehnprozentigen
beiden main ist ein geschmacksträger
unter yogurt schmeckt einfach besser das
halt schön cremig und ist schön fest und
ich hatte nicht so flüssig
wenn man das natürlich auch in 35
genehme nehme ich da einfach mal 500
gramm
das dürfte zu reichen dann biste
knoblauch und da nehme ich jetzt nicht
viel weiter
je mehr man nimmt um so gut um so mehr
stinkt man dann halt auch auf weniger
freunde hat weniger freunde hat mal
genauer hat und ich bin so ein hauch das
reicht schon habe ich gestern auch so
gemacht und der moral hat gestimmt weil
ich selber gegessen habe das ist immer
das problem wenn wir ihn bei gemachtes
essen dann dann ist es kein problem ja
nur einer ist dann kommt noch salz ein
so ungefähr halben teelöffel und
ordentlich pfeffer und dass ich so mein
lieblingsjob ort wie ich ihn am liebsten
esse auch zum beispiel zum grillen im
sommer
und wenn man das ein bisserl noch burke
ryan gibt hat man hat ein leckeres tasci
assist taticek
wenn ich kurz stehen lassen und jetzt
kann ich hier in meinem job ist den
unternehmen die sich jetzt ohne die ich
noch kalt das ist jetzt so eine typische
soße und zwar macht man das gerne
übermannte also über die maultaschen
aber auch über andere gerichte vor allem
halt über joghurt gerichte und ich nehme
als car zum stück das sind ungefähr 30
gramm vater moral und jetzt lasse ich
das kurz erhitzen bis die butter eben
geschmolzen ist
jetzt gebe ich das paprikapulver mit
dazu und wartet nicht so gerne so scharf
markt nimmt halt nicht dieses schafe
sondern edelsüß heißt es hat glaube ich
und das treffen scharf genau
und da gibt es einfach so nach gefühl
rein also auf 30 gramm butter habe ich
jetzt etwa gehäuften teelöffel genau und
ist auch so der typische geruch in der
türkischen küche finde ich das mache ist
kennenlernen machen das auch ärger über
den ist kenntlich machen uns über alles
verstehen ja viele mache es auch mit
tomatenmark aber ich finde zuvor mit
paprika total lecker wenn ich das ist
einfach gut aber schmeckt auch gut so
ich hole ich es meine noten schnecken
aus dem ofen und dann öfter morath
probieren
ich sage jetzt mal eine aber natürlich
es mir gleich viel mehr nach vorn
vor ungefähr vier oder drei oder vier
staffeln
ich weiß nicht ich glaube alles ist
jetzt gebe ich die joghurt soße darauf
also ich liebte es halt vor allem nehmen
wenn diese schnecken dann so ganz heißen
und der joghurt ganz kalt und dann noch
diese leckere würzigen soße dazu also
dass die schlechten
fragt mich wie es schmeckt ich weiß also
schmecken ja aus wie sehr wir müssen
alles schaut dieses aber das ist
wirklich herr schauen das kann jetzt
auch eine schnecke sein so ist es und so
ich habe gerade eine knoblauch reiber
die nase die registrierten in die nase
ich hab meine knoblauch waren
so sitzt ihnen aus genau darüber
als ich meine murat eigentlich nichts
dazu sagen ich weiß dass es schmeckt und
ich glaube die zuschauer wissen dass ich
niemals sagen
widerlich was schmeckt ja auch nicht mit
also ich hab den joghurt gar nicht
abgespeckt ich hoffe es hat aber schenke
ich mache das jetzt jedoch fertig machen
ein foto für instagram und facebook
morath genießen doch sein stück und dann
gehen sich auch mein stück und ihr dürft
gerne das rezept komplett nachlesen auf
cds blog.de und dies auch gerne
nachmachen und mir ein foto schicken
und ich freue mich dann schon wieder
aufs nächste mal bis bald